It's time for a new segment that we're calling
"Drew in your Business,"
where I help entrepreneurs take their businesses
to the next level.
And I am so excited to kick off this segment
with a woman who is just as sweet as her business.
Take a look.
My name is Stephanie Davidson
and I'm the owner of Oh for the Love of Cheesecakes.
I make these yummy and scrumptious cheesecakes,
and I did the unthinkable.
In the middle of a pandemic,
when unemployment rates are super high,
I quit my good job to stay
at home and make these cheesecakes.
Now, becoming an entrepreneur is very scary
and I'm not gonna lie, it's hard.
I consider Drew to be the ultimate businessperson
and I have my pen and my paper,
and I'm ready to take notes.
Drew, will you help me?
Thank you, Stephanie.
And yes, I would love to!
I'd love to get up in your business.
Stephanie, where are you?
(audience applauds)
I'm right here! Hi Drew!
Hi Stephanie.
Thank you so much for coming
on the show and telling us about your amazing business.
I just want to ask a question that I would think
if I was watching, this would be my first burning question,
which is how did you do this in the middle
of a pandemic, quit a job, and how is it going?
It's going really good.
You know, I was at work and I was sitting
behind a computer and I'm just like looking
out at the sun and, you know, I just wanted more.
And I started making cheesecakes
for people at work for their birthdays.
And they started saying, "You should make these.
You should sell these."
And I'm like, "No, I can't do that."
And they said, "Yes, you should."
Well, that idea just kind of grew and grew and grew.
And what I learned in 2020 is
that you just got to jump in and take that risk.
Do you think that you are happier now?
Oh, most definitely. Most definitely.
(hands clap) You don't understand how happy
that makes me, 'cause I know,
I know there are people who are afraid to take the leap
and there is that thing about the importance
of happiness and it is not some BS, lofty, mug.
It's not, it's like a hard earned.
You have to fight for it.
You have to reconfigure your life.
You have to keep working on yourself.
You have to take risks.
It's hard to be happy.
It is, when you are the one
that's putting in all the work.
You have to do this and you get so much back.
Like to me, it's the biggest high
that I can get is when somebody looks
at my cheesecakes and says, "Oh my gosh, that is so pretty."
Or that's so beautiful.
It tastes so amazing.
That makes it all worth it for me.
Okay, so how has business been?
It's actually grown quite fast.
It's a little overwhelming at times.
Last Thanksgiving, in 2019, I had seven cheesecakes
and I thought, "Oh my gosh,
how am I gonna do seven cheesecakes?"
Well, this past Thanksgiving,
it was anywhere between 110 to 120 cheesecakes.
Oh my gosh.
So it has grown a lot.
Do I have this right
that you have five ovens and three refrigerators?
I do. I do.
I love picturing that.
As soon as I read that
I could just see you like just,
with the spinning plates and multitasking and doing it all.
And is that what the current work process looks like?
Spinning plates and running to ovens
and fridges and managing 130 orders for one Thanksgiving?
Yeah, that was quite the task.
I have to give props to Excel,
because my spreadsheet was what kept me going.
But yes, you know, you're constantly switching
out your cheesecakes.
Oh, this one's done.
Then you put another one in.
Oh, now I gotta run over to this oven.
This one's done.
So I got to take that out,
put another one in.
This one needs cooled,
so I need to move it to the counter.
Well, now it's in the second phase of cooling.
So now I got to move it to the refrigerator.
So yeah, there's a lot of spinning plates.
Does it, it sounds like that.
Does it look like this?
Dah nah nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee neerum, neerum!
Yes, it does.
(laughs)
Not as graceful, though, as you.
(laughs) Oh, I highly doubt that.
Okay. What are your goals now?
My goal is that I've actually outgrown
my kitchen space here.
I want to get that storefront.
I want to be able to have that cheesecake.
Somebody comes in for a piece of cheesecake
over a cup of coffee with their BFF
on a weekday afternoon.
I want a place for people to hang out, study,
but be able to come to the counter when they need one
and one's right there,
or continue to have that customized cheesecake
but also not lose that one-on-one feeling
that what I first started with.
Okay, so it's like Julia Childs meets Central Perk.
Okay. I get it.
(upbeat music)